the southern port of marseille is in a
region with one of the highest
unvaccinated populations in france until
recently nico core was among them when
we first met him a year ago he didn't
want a coveted vaccine because he
worried about possible side effects but
he has since changed his mind and just
had his second jab
i had many questions about the vaccine's
effectiveness what's in it it was a
personal decision and i decided to say
no to being vaccinated but the situation
has since evolved
there's a fifth wave the omicron variant
we now know children are a major source
of transmission and my wife is a teacher
so my environment has changed and on
balance i decided it was better to get
vaccinated
france has registered record numbers of
new covid infections doctors say most
people in hospital with the virus are
unvaccinated so the government wants to
pressure those who are not immunised to
get a jab by introducing a vaccine pass
for most social activities
last week french mps approved the pass
after days of fierce debate
people in france have to have a covered
health pass if they want to catch a
train go to the movies or even be in a
restaurant like this it is a qr code
that most people have on their telephone
that effectively shows whether you've
been fully vaccinated or have a recent
negative test but the government want to
change the rules so that only people who
are vaccinated will be able to access
the past which means people who are
unvaccinated will no longer be able to
do things like this
the measure has infuriated people who
are against the covet vaccine on
saturday thousands protested in paris
against the past and against the french
president who recently made
controversial comments about
unvaccinated people
it is an attack on our freedom i am not
vaccinated and macron does not respect
the constitution he has insulted me as a
citizen
this opposition mp says the pass is an
erosion of rights and the wrong approach
persuade people to get vaccinated you
have to respect them we have a high
vaccination rate nearly 90 percent but
we need to convince people who are
unvaccinated not necessarily because
they are against it but because they
don't have enough information
while some say the vaccine pass is
divisive emmanuel macron bet on most
people in france supporting it because
the majority are immunized opinion polls
suggest he was right three months before
the presidential election mcgraw is
hoping that his risky political
calculation will pay off
natasha butler al jazeera marseilles